jean-mi siens on ne présente plus belles
cravates et j'adore votre blouson assez
ça veut dire quoi ben ça veut dire à ses
arêtes paris et jean messia spécialiste
de foot mais au fait de longues en
restions prix le mec a mis la c1 tarbes
a ou pas sera gâté vous savez ce que ça
veut dire par vous avez à y gagner une
sorte de moule à gâteau une éthique
amazon la fumée ce soir ton mais pas une
bonne année quand omar sy a joué arsène
lupin oui il y avait pas d'acteur blanc
suffisamment talentueux pour jouer
arsène l'humain qui lie à une racaille
isation de la jeunesse française
[Applaudissements]
ban ki moon mais je reste mais c'est
vrai que si vous devez regarder beaucoup
cette année vous n'avez pas pu passer à
côté de jean messia jean messia qui est
comme fabrice di vizio qui est venu très
souvent dans l'émission et c'est vrai
qu'on s'est souvent clash et tous les
deux alors et je tiens à le dire jean
mathia même si on est d'accord sur rien
jean messier moi c'est vrai que c'est
quand même on est en france et voilà
antipas mine de rien c'est pas pour ça
que je n'aime pas je me fais 1 0 je
préfère discuter avec lui et parfois
voilà lui montrer qu'il a tort et lui
montrer parfois que j'ai raison mais
c'est vrai qu'on se classent souvent et
que il a eu un problème et jean je te le
dis c'est que c'est vrai que autant que
chez pascal praud tu es très sage
autant chez moi tu en mets partout
comment expliques-tu ça j'explique ça
parce que très souvent je suis quand
même pas enfin je suis seul qui est seul
contre la défendre voilà c'est ça et
donc évidemment quand quand vous avez x
personnes et que je suis tout seul à
dire ce que je dis alors que toutes les
autres personnes ont à peu près le même
discours
forcément je suis obligé de me 2,2 me
démultiplier pour dire ce que j'ai à
dire
mais avant de rentrer dans le vif du
sujet je tiens à te dire mais sans
aucune flagornerie de ma part que c'est
vrai que c'est il a fallu connaît un
certain courage je lui quand j'ai
commencé à venir participer à tpm paix
parce que beaucoup des gens qui me
soutiennent n'était pas d'accord avec ma
participation est probablement que
beaucoup de téléspectateurs n'étaient
pas non plus d'accord avec ma présence
et je trouve que ce talk show c'est
cette émission est très intéressante
parce que tu es l'un des rares cyril je
te le dis en face à avoir le courage
d'inviter toutes les tendances
politiques y compris celles parfois que
personne d'autre l'invitons aux antilles
pas exactement
je me souviens respecte non résidentes
mais non mais c'est à dire le fait
d'inviter quelqu'un n'est pas cautionner
sa pensée étant dans une démocratie
moderne comme la france à partir du
moment où les idées que tu défends ce
sont des idées légal que tu ne dis pas
quelque chose qui enfreint la loi
eh bien tu as le droit de les exprimer
si des gens ont un problème avec ce que
tu dis ils ont qu'a porté plainte c'est
que la loi qui délimite la liberté
d'expression c'est pas le fait de
choquer ou le fait de pas être d'accord
bon ça c'est une chose la deuxième chose
c'est qu'effectivement sur les autres
plateaux de télévision en tous cas en
dehors du groupe canal on a une forme de
commande yazd idéologie dominante qui
dont je vais pas détailler les les
comment dirais-je les dogmes et les
français suffoque de cette ut de cette
unicité de 7,2 cette pensée unique qui
ne laisse place à aucune voix
discordante
depuis peu on assiste de plus en plus à
des ouvertures sur ces news sur ces 8 et
les français adorent parce que comme
disait montaigne il faut avoir une tête
pour avoir une tête bien faite plutôt
que bien pleine et bien il faut se
frotter la cervelle il faut se frotter
la cervelle qu'il faut se limiter à ces
rebelles contrôlent outre les autres
donc moi j'apprécie de venir ici et je
terminerai en disant que quand on m'a
beaucoup critiqué pour ma présence ici
j'ai fait une vidéo sur ma chaîne
youtube j'ai fait un papier pour
expliquer pourquoi je venais ici parce
que il en va de l'honneur de la
démocratie française que devenir avoir
le courage de défendre ses convictions
partout et surtout là où ben vous et le
public et l'audience ne vous est pas
acquise par définition moi je n'aime pas
un combat pour ma personne je me bats
pour mes idées
donc moi je veux dire si l'année
prochaine je suis habité d'une part
c'est pas grave moi je ne vis pas de ça
j'ai un boulot à côté chez aux
fonctionnaires voilà je ne vis pas de ça
je viens ici parce que ça me plaît de
débattre parce que ça me plaît de vous
voir certains d'entre vous on est même
devenu une mode avec des relations
conviviales etc
j'ai pas de problème etc ca ayant une
dernière dernière chose je n'ai personne
d'accord j'aime tout le monde je
simplement quand on me dit que j'ai
honte de mes origines je n'ai pas honte
de mes origines je suis quelqu'un qui
parle arabe couramment qui intervient
souvent dans des chaînes satellitaire en
langue arabe qui intervient sur france
24 en arabe qui a même écrit des
articles en arabe j'ai lu le coran en
arabe
donc ne me dites pas que qu'on me dise
pas que j'ai honte de mes origines les
gens qui me disent ah en fait eux mêmes
ne savent pas ce qu'est l'euro ce que
sont leurs origines d'accord
probablement qu'ils ne maîtrisent pas
les origines comme je maîtrise les
miennes mais a par contre le fait d'être
le fait d'être commandés âge fier d'être
français
ce que je suis aussi ne signifie pas
prôner honte de ses origines jusqu'aux
et en france et qu'en france on ne peut
pas dire d'un côté vous avez honte de
vos origines et quand on parle d origine
de quelqu'un on lit bien vous êtes
raciste vous le ramener à ses origines
faut savoir soit vous sacraliser les
origines soit vous soit vous sacraliser
le fait d'être français mais on peut
être normal on peut être fier d'être
français et allait être fier de ses
origines ce que je dis et je n'ai
personne
bon alors si je renvoie les parties gens
non mais c'est vrai que j'en médias il a
dit un truc travail c'est pas parce
qu'on invite quelqu'un qu'on est
d'accord c'est le cas dans cette
émission je vous dis on essaie de donner
la parole à tout le monde dans un
instant de rats francis lalanne parce
que on a entendu la version de l'équipe
de quotidien ça va bien entendu et voilà
tous cru mais on donne aussi la parole à
francis lalanne qui a envie de nous
donner sa version francis et peut-être
quand on entendra sa version sera manqué
ce qui ne sera plus comme il se dissout
ça nous faisait souvent rêvé tirs jets
abidjan - wi2wi un nom oui bah moi il
suffit jamais d'accord avec vous mais en
revanche sûrement heureux de toutes mes
forces pour que vous puissiez vous
exprimer tout votre très important et je
pense qu'il faut absolument pas vous
bâillonnée pour deux raisons d'abord
parce que je pense que quand on
bâillonne on victimiser ça ne fonctionne
pas au contraire il faut débattre dans
l'opposition il faut échanger nos idées
nos points de vue ça c'est la première
chose
et deuxième chose c'est que quand on
fait des sondages et bien les
téléspectateurs vont souvent dans votre
sens mais donc je pense qu'il ya aussi
une partie de la delà de la france de
nos téléspectateurs de voilà qui pense
aussi comme moi je pense que c'est très
important justement de éventuellement
les faire évoluer dans ce que j'estime
mois peut-être la bien pensante en tout
cas le bon sens et je pense que donc
c'est très important et puis si jamais
vous venez plus on pourra toujours faire
un point habillement parce que quand
vous êtes au niveau cravate il faut
chaud chaud
wanda guillaume non je pense que les
gens mais cela il a prouvé une chose
c'est qu'on peut ne pas être d'accord
avec les idées politiques de quelqu'un
et échanger avec lui et lui trouver des
qualités humaines et moi j'ai pas peur
de le dire jean médecin je trouve que
c'est quelqu'un d'extrêmement
sympathique à l'antenne comme hors
antenne et je trouve que c'est peut-être
ça aussi on est d'accord avec nous sur
maintenant je suis d'accord avec
quasiment aucune de ces idées il le sait
mais on peut rigoler avec quelqu'un on
peut avoir des échanges humains alors
qu'on n'est pas du tout d'accord avec
ses idées et je trouve que c'est un bon
exemple pour sa jambe et ya un an gilles
verdez il fait du mal à l'émission et
rabâché vieille usuels cirgl vous fait
du mal à vous il ne vous obéit pas ça je
ne supporte pas ce que tu pas d'hier à
propos de zemmour répète lui là vous
passez votre temps à vous écouter vous
n'écoutez jamais les autres je pense
qu'une pause de quelques années de
silence lui sera d'un grand démocrate
alors c'est ce que j'aime justement chez
vous c'est qu'il n'a pas peur de vous
rentrez dedans cyril et vous aimez ça
aussi donc la vapeur de débat c'est ce
qu'on aime et 10 collard chaque fois
écoutez moi je pense qu'on est
aujourd'hui dans une société du courroux
du compte qui est ultra dangereuse et
qui a plus de débat au moins gens ils
amènent le débat qu'on soit d'accord ou
pas d'accord avec lui et pour combattre
l'ignorance
il faut qu'il ait toujours deux parties
voilà est-ce que vous êtes arrivé à
instaurer cette saison c'est d'avoir
toujours les deux parties sur le plateau
donc on n'est pas toujours d'accord avec
les deux invités un peu de temps en
temps il ya les bons et les méchants
mais ce qui est important c'est
d'entendre les deux paroles et pour
combattre l'ignorance et pour comprendre
les choses puisqu'ils représentent quand
même un pan de la société
je pense que c'est bien qu'il soit là ou
alors autrement et puis les drôles
pardon il avait pris les devants je
n'aurais voulu cette amoureuse c'est pas
pareil d'accord avec guillaume et dire
que quel que soit ce qu'on pense de vos
idées vous êtes sympathique vous aimez
vous échanger de l'argent
valérie mais serait ce pas le bon
argument tpm et c'est une agora
donc voilà c'est le lieu c'est une agora
chien est le lieu où s'exerce la
démocratie et où tous les points de vue
peuvent venir s'exprimer et vous êtes le
garant de sa série puisque vous êtes le
premier à faire venir s'exprimer des
points de vue y compris des points de
vue extrêmes sur ce plateau qu'on entend
sur la gauche
c'est pas quoi et donc est ce qui est
donc c'est intéressant et c'est ce qui
est absolument agréable aussi amusant
mais ça c'est qu'ils acceptent de venir
se frotter y compris avouent-ils malmené
quand même pas mal et donc voilà
et donc on a la france insoumise on a eu
et rennes on a les écologistes on a le
centre le centre à droite la gauche est
bas et c'est tout à votre honneur et de
et je pense que c'est ici que s'exerce
la réflexion on peut évidemment débattre
combattre parfois mais le débat d'idées
ça et voilà et c'est à mon avis le sens
même de l'adn de tpm paix tu me blanco
c'est vrai qu'ici l'agora ça veut dire
chaîne place bordée d'édifices publics
centres de vie politique religieuse
économique de la cité j'avoue on est une
agora voir ce qu'ont pensé
téléspectateurs merci oui à 63% non à
37% bas merci jean bessière si donc vous
viendrez pouvoir
[Applaudissements]